Welcome back!
In the first part of this lecture
we have seen some simple examples of
how to define functions in Haskell
and especially how that
differs from most contemporary languages.
We have seen that in Haskell
conditionals are expressions, not
statements
but that Haskell programmers rather
write
guarded equations than conditional
expressions.
The other thing we have seen is how
to define functions
using pattern matching.
And we have seen in particular how to
define functions over lists
using pattern matching. What we're going
to look at now
is how to define functions, because
Haskell is a functional language
so we have to have a way, a concise way
to define functions. And that is
lambda expressions.
You probably know lambda expressions
from the language that you're using.
If you are a Java programmer
in Java 8 the lambda expressions
were introduced.
If you are a C# programmer, you
know lambda expressions.
If you are a Hack or PHP programmer
you have lambda expressions. In
JavaScript you have lambda expressions.
Lambda expressions are
everywhere. C++, you name it, D
Swift, every modern language has lambda
expressions. And as we saw in the very
first lecture
this was an invention from Alonzo Church
in the 1930s.
In most languages lambda expressions
look similar
and in Haskell they look as follows:
They look like this:
Lambda x, arrow, body of the lambda
expression.
In the actual code that you type
you don't write the lambda.
You write the slash, so you write \x
and instead of the arrow you write
-> but since we
want these slides to look fancy
we are
actually writing a lambda and a real arrow.
But when you write this in code,
you write slash
for the lambda and you just write the
arrow
as you would expect. So what is this
thing?
This is a function that takes an x
and adds it
to itself. And that function has no name,
so it's an expression
of function type. That's what lambda
expressions are.
They are expressions that denote
functions.
In mathematics and
as Church designed them,
if you read the lambda calculus literature, they're
written as a lambda, but we type them
as
backslash and instead of the arrow
symbol
we write the arrow symbol.
But for the rest Haskell, I think, is a
language that is closest to the lambda
calculus
because it's based on pure functions,
whereas
in other languages lambda expressions are
I think a better way would be to call
them closures.
And we will see why, because they can
close over variables
in the outer scope. But these lambda
expressions can have side effects.
But as we said it doesn't really
matter.
We are really emphasizing the fact that
functional programming is
programming using expressions. So why are
lambda expressions useful?
Well, they are useful, because they allow
you to express your intent better
when you're currying functions. Let's
look at this first example here.
Instead of writing add x y = x+y
so this is a curried definition
This is a function that takes
a parameter x
returns a function that takes a
parameter y
and then returns x plus y. Really
the intent is better expressed by this:
add is a function
that takes a parameter x, returns a
function that takes a parameter y
and then adds them together.
This is actually syntactic sugar
for this and when I write Haskell I often
write them in this form.
Even though it's a little bit longer
it means that I have to type more
characters
but I think this form is more readable
than that form.
And in the course of
these lectures we will switch
between
both of these. But again, if you look
at my Haskell code
I prefer to write things using explicit
lambdas to convey
the actual meaning of a curried
function. Lambda expressions
are also useful when you want to
make explicit that you're returning a
function. That's
in some sense the same as currying,
but here
if we define a constant function
so this is a function that given an a will
return a function that whatever b
you give it, will return that a. So
here it's defined: const of x
returns a function that will, whatever
you give it, just ignore it
and return x. So that constant
function there
is very concisely defined using a
lambda expression
whereas here I think it's a little bit
less clear.
Const of x underscore equals x.
This one doesn't make explicit
the fact
that you are returning a function. So here
it is also emphasized by putting the
parentheses
around the type and here you don't do that.
This is how I would write
this function. I would
put the parentheses on the type and I
write the function as a lambda expression.
Here is another use of lambda expressions.
And that's to avoid inventing names.
Inventing names is
one of the hardest things that we have
to do with programming.
Coming up with meaningful names, because often
the language forces you to
name something where you just don't want
to name it. You just want to pass the thing
directly.
For example: if I want to map a
function
over a list, there is no reason I should
give that function here
a name f. And what does f say anyway?
So instead, what I can do, I can just
pass a lambda expression to the map
and that will be used to map this
function
over the list. This is
not idiomatic Haskell. This
is idiomatic Haskell. Really the only
place where you want to name something, is
when you use it more than once.
Or if it becomes clear, but that's
up to interpretation. Here is another
oddity of Haskell and that's called
sections.
With sections you can take
a binary operator, an infix operator,
like plus
and use it as a function. So by putting
parentheses around it, you can use plus as a
function. So 1+2
equals 3 and plus in parentheses
1 2 is also 3. This is a nice trick
because we can also put
(1+) and we can do
(+2) So we can section, we can
partially apply + by putting
parentheses around the plus. Here we see:
We can do (1+) which is a function
that expects a second argument, and will
add 1 to it. And here we have the function
section, (+2) which is a function that
expects
a value here and then adds it
to it. So this is 1+2 equals 3.
In general
if funny plus is a binary
operator
then you can write plus in parentheses
to use it as a normal function
and you can left or right section it by
partially applying it to an argument.
This is something that you will
see quite a lot in Haskell
specially here, if you want to have a
function that increments something
you just write (1+) as a section. Why
are sections useful?
Here are a couple of examples. You
want a function that takes an
argument and halves it?
You just write (/2)
And you don't have to write lambda x
x divided by 2. So sectioning allows
you to write something
without inventing a name. And that's
the whole goal of this exercise.
Giving names is hard, so we want to avoid
that.
And sectioning allows you to do that.
Here is a preview of the
exercises. The exercises will be
available on the website.
And in these exercises we will ask you
to use some of these constructs that
we have seen in this lecture to define
functions. And as I promise you, this will
be the last
exercise that's very Haskell
specific
but since we have been
talking about how Haskell
differs from other languages, I think
it's quite useful
to follow the rest of the lectures to
do these exercises
to get a little bit familiar
with the Haskell syntax. Happy hacking
and see you next week. Bye bye.